titanfall is a game about movement
hee-hoo parcours gets around the map
faster is more likely to win gunfights
and gets domination captures before the
enemy team knows what hit them with that
in mind here the top parkour styles that
will get you moving like a pro well
start this off general with the bouncer
the bouncer is always in motion since
wall running gives players a speed
boosts the bouncer understands that
there's no good reason to run on the
ground like a chump
there are many routes in titanfall that
will get you across the map in no time
so memorizing the best ways to go is
this player style leap off friendly
Titans heads for height advantage equip
advanced park horn stems to make giant
leaps a lesser pilot can't one great
move for the bouncer is to pull the luke
skywalker's Sarlacc pit maneuver when
being shot at on rooftops quickly
dropped down to give the illusion that
you've fallen to the ground only to wall
jump back up and blasts that lurid
pursuer
in the face moving all the time not your
style more of a defensive player you my
friend are a stage five clinger the
stage five clinger wall hangs everyday
all day take an objective and just hang
out with your smart pistol waiting for
prey to fall into the trap the stage
five clinger also likes to hang on to
all sorts of objects cling on to a
friendly Strider for the best view in
town or cling on to an enemy Titan and
lay c4 on their head parts before
running away to find another perch the
clinger has a few options with loadouts
but if you plan to find the best perches
maybe opt for an anti Titan rocket to
give you range the clinger will
occasionally descend from above and
knows how to do this belong ki leaping
from wall to wall pausing as you descend
to check for a nasty case of the bad
guys clinging still sound like too much
effort let's say you're just a lazy
parkour or will grab a spark pistol
because aiming is hard and find yourself
a zipline there are many great things at
the end of ziplines next the break
Titans to rodeo objectives to capture
other zip lines when capturing a base
the lazy parkour
just finds a corner cloaks and weights
packed hurt so they shoot grunts and
grind down your Titan timer for you then
let your Titan fight on its own speaking
of the lazy parkour herb doesn't waste
all that time in rodeo shooting the
Titans head part's over and over again
no the lazy Park horror expends just
enough effort to convince the enemy
pilot to exit and then takes them out
some burn cars are made for this play
styled use the specter camo card as to
minimize the amount of fighting and
running necessary since enemy pilots
won't know you're a pilot until it's too
late
alternatively equipped radar so you
don't have to go looking for people to
kill because looking is hard
our final play style elevates above the
rest
this player wants to get so high they
can practically hit the skybox yes it's
the premature ejector this guy gets into
Titan just to manually eject for height
advantage hang time is long enough with
the manual eject feature that you can
get an anti Titan rocket off before you
hit the ground if you're gonna blow
early make sure to equip your Titan with
nuclear eject and auto eject to get
maximum coverage grab a Strider to get
into groups of enemy Titans quickly and
explode even faster well that's all for
our top parkour styles in titanfall
we're still working on the Nick Cage
maneuver from Firebirds
hanging onto edges of ledges before
committing and other such shenanigans
what are your best parkour moves let us
know in the comments below and we'll be
happy to rodeo you out on the
battlefield
you
[Music]